[Música]
bom dia na nomeava eu falarei sobre o
pinheiros é só esse tema porque eu gosto
muito de pesca esportes aquáticos
por isso eu me preocupo muito com a
poluição de mares e rios
eu sou um dia poder ver os filhos nossas
cidades poluídos
o rio pinheiros é urbano localizado na
cidade de são paulo é nasce do encontro
do rio grande com rio guarapiranga e
deságua no rio tietê tem 25 quilômetros
de extensão no passado que o pinheiro já
foi usado para o abastecimento de água
para a população e geração de energia
elétrica no enade henry borden o caso já
vem cubatão para isso suas águas eram
bombeados no sentido contrário de seu
curso natural para o reservatório
billings
até a década de 1930 a população sofria
do rio é fã de esportes aquáticos
porém o rio e seus afluentes passaram a
receber ou industriais outro do méxico o
que polui os sábados na cidade de são
paulo 88 por cento das casas possuem
rede de coleta de esgoto e 75% são
atendidas pelo sistema de tratamento de
esgoto
o restante lançado nos fios na cidade de
são paulo são quase 300 toneladas de
esgoto por dia
a situação piora ainda mais se
considerarmos a região em que se
encontram os afluentes do rio pinheiros
infelizmente transformaram no pinheiros
gotas céu aberto
amo eo pinheiros existem quatro pontos
de monitoramento das águas em 2016
o índice de qualidade das águas nos
quatro pontos um foi regular e outros
três foram péssimos oxigênio dissolvido
na água é de fundamental importância
para sobreviver
desorganizado de jacquard erros porém em
2016 não nos quatro pontos e atingiu 20
mínimo recomendado hoje em cena eo temos
exemplos clássicos dos recuperados nos
dois casos foram feitos grandes
investimentos em saneamento básico ou
seja na rede de coleta e tratamento de
esgoto
também foram feitos grandes
investimentos na disposição das águas já
poluídas
mas o que me chamou a atenção foi o
resgate do convívio da população com os
fios nos verões são montadas praias às
margens do rio sena ea população ganha
novos espaços de lazer
essa medida aumentar a conscientização
ea mobilização da sociedade em favor da
expansão do rio
como vimos investimento em saneamento
básico na exposição depende do poder
público no que se alcance de nós a
sociedade civil
eu acredito no caminho seja
conscientização uma sociedade consciente
entende a necessidade de medidas simples
como por exemplo não jogar lixo nas ruas
nem no rio ou não usar o vaso sanitário
como lixeira com a conscientização à
população pode mobilizar se pressionar o
poder público
eu acredito no caminho para a
conscientização seja o resgate do
convívio da população com o rio
algumas iniciativas já estão em
andamento nesse sentido o projeto pomar
implantado em parceria com a iniciativa
privada
mais de 300 mil mudas já foram plantadas
ao longo do rio
a ciclovia pinheiros tem o objetivo de
olhar lazer transporte urbano a partir
de 2010 já tem 20 quilômetros de
extensão a ponte friderich bayern foi
concebida pela empresa bayer para
passagem de pedestres e ciclistas
o projeto prioriza o verde
eu acredito que o caminho seja buscar
nos patrocínio de empresas para
desenvolver mais
nativas do convívio da população com o
rio
minhas sugestões são bacharel sobre os
marginais para pedestres e ciclistas
terem mais pontes e acessos à ciclovia
aluguel de bicicletas na própria
ciclovia dessas margens do rio como
locais de lazer como por exemplo
pequenos palcos como esse para
apresentação de espetáculos ao ar livre
quadras esportivas locais sombreados
para recreação
enfim as possibilidades são inúmeras
basta vontade de realizar aqui tem uma
exposição perguntando o que cada um de
nós pode fazer para diminuir o impacto
da posição nos seus é minha família lá
em casa já praticamos dos três erres
reduzir reutilizar e reciclar vão salvar
nossos rios obrigadas a tensão
[Aplausos]